we already showed that the torque about
a point can also be thought of as a
decomposition we take the vector from
the point P to the center of mass and
apply all the forces acting on the
particle at the center of mass and we
can calculate the torque about the
center of mass due to the action of some
forces well we're having forces acting
about the center of mass now if we
choose the point P to equal the center
of mass then we know that the vector R
center of mass to the center of mass is
zero so the torque about the center of
mass is just equal to the forces about
that point we know that this is always
torque is always just LCM DT now again
how could we justify that statement that
because we're only calculating the
torque about the center of mass the only
it's only the rotational angular
momentum about the center of mass that's
changing we saw before that if we
thought of LP again as a translational
and a rotational angular momentum and
the point P I'm sorry rotational angular
momentum Omega and the point P was equal
to the center of mass then this first
piece would be zero and L about P is
only I see M Omega n dl P DT is equal to
I see M alpha for fixed axis and that's
exactly equal to DL cm DT and so the
point here is that when we're applying
problems involving rotation and
translation
we can just analyze the torque about the
center of mass and only consider how the
angular momentum about the center of
mass is changing and then for the center
of mass motion so this gives us our
rotational dynamics and for our linear
dynamics we will still apply F equals
the total mass times a cm so that's our
linear dynamics and this is our overall
decomposition of rotational motion to
analyze it we study the rotational
dynamics and the linear dynamics